là est bien on va jouer à big selon
keolis est parti xo
[Musique]
xo et au lycée très simple on va faire
comme dans les amours je vais poser des
questions et je vais poser des questions
je vais demander des questions à big flo
qui va devoir répondre de génie
technique puis sur poli au lit mais non
c'est le contraire pousser plus haut
qu'il abat ses flots qui s'opèrent l'a
échangé parce que j'ai trop peur et
c'est ça que je sais c'est ça ces
trottoirs
est ce qu'on peut avoir s'il vous plaît
alors c'est au lit mois ouais je sais il
olivos qu'au départ c'était lui qui
devait sauter oui je sais après vous
avez changé pour ça donc je sais mon
early tu vas tu vas monter de plus en
plus haut on va poser des questions à
ton frère sur toi [ __ ] mais c'est pas
mal on fera monter et la passerelle de
plus en plus et tu dois faire un saut
n'y a même pas un rien du tout tué a
sauté dont je crois que c est mettre à
chaque fois exactement merci je vois que
tu connais mieux les missions que
moissac il ya eu question tu pourras
aller jusqu'à lui mettre un stop stress
là d'accord on les intentions vous avez
45 secondes tu dois répondre au moins je
te dis à toutes les questions
allez vous attends attends c'est facile
à ses intrigues rapidité one ont même
pas on enlève la rapidité c'est qu'on va
le faire comme ça a
est-ce que tu connais la partie du corps
de ton frère qui le complexe le plus
oui sa calvitie oui c'est bon ça je
connais son insulte préférées [ __ ] oui
est-ce que tu connais la première chose
qu lire garde chez une fille faith je
dis pas non c'est faux non c'est ses
yeux ses yeux le projet poursuit
l'artiste qu'il qui font secret en
secret ouais la chanteur mais c'est un
chanteur animateur patrick sébastien
bien sûre et le truc de ouf qu'il a
dédicacé à une jambe en moi oui il est
trop fort 10/06 ouf ça le truc plouffe
café qui l'a fait par amour il aime
personnes
[Rires]
est ce qu'il a fait par rapport à un
truc de ouf nombre j'ai pas souvenir
faire je vais faire avec - céline nul
ban est resté et franchement c'est non
je train j'ai fait tout le temps mais ça
use il a fait toulouse bordeaux en train
aller retour et quelques heures deux
heures mais ces deux heures on irait qui
m'a dit j'ai fait toulouse à mettre le
sujet sur lequel vous n'êtes jamais
d'accord allez les filles non à part ça
l'argent non qu'est-ce qu'il a dû dire
là je sais pas là j'ai fait mon il
paraît en effet les normandes haye
pareil pour y faire quoi
attention ça va jouer sur cette question
est-ce que tu connais la durée exacte de
la plus longue relation qu'il a eu avec
une meuf
il faut exactement ces trois ans
non ces deux ans et sept mois on va le
monter à lui m avec culot
[Applaudissements]
montez le mois que tu as peur de ça que
j'ai monté mon s'est tu m'entends bah
ouais j'suis pas bien frein sur c'est
vrai mais on s'en rend pas compte je
vous jure que c'est pire est-ce qu'on
peut mettre une caméra d'or est monté
encore montant des milliers de disques
selo mois et vous m'attendais vous voyez
attentats temps je vais te dire je te
l'a juste un truc j'ai tu ne veux pas
serait ce qu on peut monter encore un
peu ce qu'on peut faire un truc sinon
nancy ville à des retards et une
solution quoi all i way jusqu'à août est
prêt pour réussir dans la musique
[Musique]
attendez j'ai une solution matthieu
delormeau n'a pas encore son billet
problème
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
matthieu delormeau n'est pas encore
qualifié pour la la belle n'a pas oublié
non plus n'ont alors vous remercie vous
le faites
ne tombez pas sur le nez vous avez rêve
est-ce que c'est gilles saute
ouais j'y sotchi tu gardes ton billet
pour la laponie quasiment gilles mathieu
non mais je peux pas mais là bas tu es
ce que tu veux bien essayer
[Applaudissements]
quels sont les pour la laponie direct et
de l'heure où il est toujours pas partir
alors je dis parce que par rapport à mes
enfants et touche je peux pas j'ai
regardé mon fils il a passé gerba des
dallages il ne sait pas qu'on va retirer
le concert au dernier moment
[Rires]
attention les séries est-ce que vous
êtes prêts sont un premier aller j'y
vais mais je suis pas bien cyrille ce
jour tu me connais on est amis je vais
faire si tu veux pas sauter sont pas
allés hier je le fais pour l'album je
fais pour toi allez allez là jamais et
on n'a jamais forcer quelqu'un à sauter
qui est ainsi du suspense à delphine
mais c'est bon mais on doute là s'il
saute c'est break comme ça mais tu te
retournes comment ils sont comme ça les
choses comme ça pour attacher ses bonnes
non sur l'effet du recul on suit les
gens snl
j'ai les pieds non allez allez allez mon
gars
[Applaudissements]
votre papa qui s'appelle comment fabián
fabienne all alone hier fabienne ordonez
est ce qu'on a fait ou pas vu le papa de
big flo et oli sur le plateau de touche
pas à mon ouïe et téléphone
suite allô allô
ah oui alors oui bonjour vous êtes le
bas rhin le pape a défloré on peut
l'applaudir pas juste un truc tu sais
qu'on ne voit pas là c'est juste le
téléphone je les adore et où je voulais
vous dire que je vous aimais beaucoup
avant est ce que vous êtes fier de big
flo et oli
je suis très fier à la vie d'avant on
commet pas être fiers de la carrière
qu'ils ont fait ça fait d'être ou de ne
pas être fier de ce qui doit arriver à
faire d'incroyables est ce que voulait
leur dire un petit mot ce soir ils sont
sur le plateau
un petit mot oui surtout rivés aux
antilles est aujourd'hui pas fier de lui
parce que moi je sais faire aussi
gros bisous il n'ya pas qui prépare son
album d'ailleurs il prépare un album
solo on travaille avec lui on y viendra
sur le plateau et je vais vous un traité
sur plateau voire carrément je
t'embrasse très fort on vous aime
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vais pas vu le big flo et oli est ce
qu'on a vu ou pas vu big flo et oli
sortir leur premier clip en 2008 pour
l'anniversaire d'isabelle morini-bosc
non merci
regardez juste en 2008 fier d'être
toulouse à regarder mais non qu'il est
loin mon pays qu'il est loin parfois au
fond de moi se ranime vivrait au lit je
vous représente
sinon c'est le locle ministre messan
toulouse celle qui sans ce qui bouge
celle qui trouve ses causes de ces
cernea pour moi qui déclarent ils sont
avec nous et c'est papa qui avait filmé
mais bon ça que ça bouge comme ça c'est
votre papa qui s'appelle comment fabián
fabienne on le gagnait fabienne ordonez
est ce qu'on a fait ou pas vu le papa de
big flo et oli sur le plateau de touche
pas à mon ouïe les téléphones tout de
suite allô allô
ah oui alors oui bonjour vous êtes le
bien et le papa des flots les on peut
l'applaudir
enfin juste un truc tu sais qu'on ne
voit pas là c'est juste le téléphone je
les adore et où je voulais vous dire que
je vous aimais beaucoup avant est ce que
vous êtes fier de big flo et oli
évidemment on ne commet pas être fiers
de la carrière qu'ils ont fait ça fait
d'être ou ne pas être que fier de qui
doit arriver à faire d'incroyables est
ce que voulait leur dire un petit mot ce
soir ils sont sur le plateau
un petit mot oui surtout rivés aux tic
et aujourd'hui pas fier de lui parce
qu'ils savent faire aussi d'un gros
bisous à ne vois pas qui prépare son
album d'ailleurs il prépare un album
solo on travaille avec lui on y viendra
sur le plateau et je vais vous arrêter
sur plateau voire carrément je
t'embrasse très fort on vous aime
est ce qu'on a vu est ce qu'on a vu big
flo et oli revendre leur nrj music
awards sur le bon coin
non non non mais on les a menés offrir
ce nrj music awards un fan sur scène
voilà c'est ça c'est depuis un an et
demi c'est la folie comme tout ce qu'on
vit c'est grâce au public aux gens qui
votent tout ça on a envie de faire un
truc un peu particulier est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un dans le public et les fans de
vie politique comme beaucoup de folie
pour les jeunes gens très bien on
voulait juste au nom de tous les gens
qui soutiennent d'hippolyte donner le
prix c'est pour toi mon frérot c'est
pour tous les gens qui nous soutiennent
[Applaudissements]
merci les gars merci beaucoup je vais
retrouver après on a demandé à tous les
jours des réseaux de nous retrouver et
oui effectivement y'a un truc du bon
coin évidemment c'est fou la part
vendues et une photo avec lui et sa
maman a mal pris et je crois qu'ils
habitent à nancy dans sa chambre il
m'envoie une photo via le client lui
faut lui faire un gros bisou
est ce qu'on a vu big flo et oli faire
des celles filles avec des gilets jaunes
pour pouvoir se rendre à leur propre
concert non non non il n'a pas dit s'il
allait regarder les amis on est bloqué
on est face à un barrage de givet jeunes
on leur dit qu'on a 8000 personnes qui
attendent et où ils sont ok de nous
laisser passer en échange de la selphy
donc celle ci après vous faites en fait
on parle comme ça parce qu'on venait de
se réveiller on était plus à ayant une
photo de nous avec genre 150 jeunes
comme ça et nous on est là pour donner
un bilan
et heureusement qu'ils ont été cool
parce que [ __ ] il y avait huit mille
personnes qui attendent et où il aurait
pu tu vois alors ils ont dit franchement
pour les gens qui ont plié en l'air on
fait des percées et phase a été vraiment
cool de leurs portes
est ce qu'on a vu thierry olive cartonné
en normandie qui relève de l'amour est
dans le pré avec son groupe de rap qui
s'appelle big flo et olives
tristesse ou la cropte là c'est vrai est
ce qu'on a vu est ce qu'on a vu if you
lie venir me clasher dans ma propre
émission
oui 3 on va toutes premières fois on est
venu c'est qu'ils ouvrent je me rappelle
à mes filles et des jeunes qui avaient
cru que c'était pour de vrai au début et
tramway
maintenant les tweets qui sait ces
connards et tour et je me rappelle très
bien voilà et ben je vous kiffe parce
que ça donc s'étaient rencontrés il ya
plus de plus que ça ouais ouais on avait
mangé ensemble
cm c'est même nous qui t'avons à écrire
pour te dire que c'était qu'on était fan
tu nous avais répondu direct et
approcher but on s'est vus dont on a été
mangé dans un hôtel ouais c'est vrai
edward on s'est plus quitté mes vieux
notable six classes de toute ma vie je
vais prendre un kebab sens lens avec des
frites
non tu trembles c'est pas le vendeur de
kebabs mais c'est le présentateur c'est
lui
cyril le plus grand des acteurs mais les
pas perdre tu feras pas grand chose je
ne ferai pas de flair même site à la
tête d'un vendeur de roses raté twitter
télé était partout c'est fatigant pour
faire tout ça t'engager quaas ausy du
pakistan tu fais de la télé alors t'es
pas présentables tellement doit lui que
les rasoirs se cacher sa barbe il se
prend pour une star depuis qu'il fait du
cinéma il a joué dans le dernier star
wars shuback hanouna et on repart à
l'attaqué n'est pas qu'on évitait les
ballons des parcs ont extrait les maths
en éclats des barrages avec un de ses
rares la new look a le courage de maille
n'en faudrait qu'on arrête parce que
comme tout le monde en garde les
missions le soir en cacher mais on est
des mythos ou parce qu on est juste des
poteaux mais personne ne croit chez nous
cyril on peut prendre une photo la ville
rêve et c'est vrai que tu changes du
rêve mais je peux vous dire c'est
vraiment des gens qui aiment le public
c'est vraiment les deux à 10 m le plus
et qu'ils aiment ça i kif et fort était
vraiment des artistes incroyables